[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want we
got Timmy back I am back from my
honeymoon yeah it was where'd you go I
went to the Maldives which is a small
dice mahatma dance maldives which is
like a small cluster of islands south of
India he couldn't go on his honeymoon
immediately cuz he has an immigrant wife
yeah yeah that's true that's you so so
you know like we got married like like a
year and a half ago I was there yes you
were oh you guys were all there oh but
we weren't at our honeymoon how do you
know she's not using you for the green
card those I heard about foreign women
oh because she got it already and she's
still here oh but how long does she need
to be here before she if oh I love it
let's create doubt in this marriage
there's a good question no no well
here's the thing
because in the immigration process like
when you bring someone over you have to
sign something that says even if y'all
divorce you're responsible for them for
like ten years
whoa yeah I saw I'm following 90 days
what the [ __ ] of we've been watching
yeah what's 90 days to get married you
have the 90 even the whole green card
process is a [ __ ] like even if you do
it like the right way which is which is
what we did what's the right way the
right way I'm going to tell you is you
apply for the proper visa which is the
k1 or the 90-day visa the fiance visa
and applying for all that was like good
like took like a good six to eight
months we have to get all you know
pictures of us and then she had to do
like it she had to do an interview or
just about you know like pictures of us
like Candida she's like yes relation
like no hit no pictures of us from you
like you're moving that we're a real
couple the movie pictures it's not just
doing the same shirt in one day why'd
you show me blog channel hem subscribe
no exactly that's why I'm saying it so
luckily we had a bunch of [ __ ] so we got
a proof of the visa got the visa after
like six to eight months so so after you
get this fiance visa you have three
months 90 days
is to get Mary or her to come to the
United States on that visa specifically
and then get married oh but here's what
was [ __ ] up right
so our wedding when you guys came to our
wedding it wasn't our legal wedding
because we didn't have the visa yet oh
yeah well so we didn't we couldn't make
it a legal thing so you guys decided to
do it then then instead of one because
we thought we were gonna have the visa
by then because we we booked we booked
the venue like a year ahead of time like
we're good but then the process was so
stupid it took forever we didn't get it
until maybe like a month after the
official wedding so then that's so hard
a synchronizer yeah exactly so she after
the wedding she she went to Canada for
like two more weeks is getting shipped
together and then came back on that visa
and then we just went to the courthouse
made it legal all right so then after
you do that right after be legally
married before you can travel or
anything like that
she has to apply for the green card and
that was another like ten month process
where then and then also we had to go on
an interview together and the guy just
asked you know so how'd you guys meet
blah blah blah did you feel stigmatized
for America immigrant no but I'll tell
you what those asking she do you speak
when we went on our interview I was
excited because it was dope because um
like there's different interviewers to
pop out and I saw like one guy Popeye
he's like an older Asian do different
doors the guy that popped out I thought
most like Allison Asian dude I was like
okay hopefully we get him well be him he
might he might know he might know me
right and then so [ __ ] we walk in and
like we're chillin and then he's like
well first of all I'm a no fan of your
videos I looked at us like we're good to
go right so then you know we've got
Poots for that [ __ ] but the whole
process took like I want to say like
almost two years to get the green
that's actually super fast two years the
other countries people from other
countries
well it's good she's from Canada yeah
it's not from a stigmatized country
what a long story to tell us that
someone's offending your videos that was
the whole point so yeah I'm really
famous I'm just really interested cuz I
know that process is so difficult and
it's kind of because a lot of people
scam the system and then they get paid
to get married and stuff a lot of people
think if you go around that system and
hey we're just gonna go to Vegas and get
married like you you get to bypass the
system but it makes it even more
difficult for you because really Shady
well it looks Shady and because then
they're like you know our interviews are
really quick is calling okay you did
everything right okay then this is
probably legit but for the people who
just go do it behind the system they're
they're they're more likely to like
scrutinize your [ __ ] you know and be
like what is this real imagine being
some middle-aged white guy who actually
falls in love with some chick like a
broad like some some young chicks a
asian chick and you're like look I know
at this looks like [ __ ] I swear to god I
love this chick like it's weird just
look like a creep take it there's nobody
everybody's interviewing you yeah oh
really oh really really
yeah but that's why she couldn't travel
for like a year she can work for a year
just at home living off Miami JK news
checks you know what so she had to just
stay in the states for a whole year she
couldn't go back to Canada yeah that's
why we never went on the honeymoon
so is it because if she went back and
she didn't come home yeah Wow so now you
guys to travel anywhere now the only way
she can she can legally work so what are
you gonna do now I wonder why that is
like there's like a rule like if you if
you're applying for green card or
whatever you have to stay in the states
that's so weird I think they want to
prevent people from just like getting
married and then just going back home
like if it was fake Michael coming at me
and I'm go home and do my thing like I
reckon deal with my real husband yeah
exactly factor activity probably mmm so
what's she gonna be doing now
so back in Canada she owned like a salon
she was an aesthetician where she liked
manicures pedicures wax wax vaginas sit
like that but John yeah
she waxed coochies and [ __ ] Wow she
heard that be real waxed in oh yeah Oh
check this out it better be
professionally done check this out I
[ __ ] before we went on the honeymoon
she waxed her ass yeah she couldn't go
to a girl to get waxed so I [ __ ]
helped her helped her wax her couch then
like her [ __ ] area so she was like
babe you're just gonna have to help me I
can't I don't have time to go to
somebody she had her little setup with
her wax right that you know she just has
and then so she tries there with like
her [ __ ] like legs up with a mirror
and she's like and she would take the
wax he replies hi babe I'm just gonna
hold it really time gonna hold it and
then you take and then you just pull
down right yeah just like it's like us
you don't think you just said this the
immigration office okay this shit's real
well this was like a month ago so yeah
and I was like and I was like are you
scared and I was I was nervous I do you
like babying it okay I can't baby cuz
you know if you ban me there's like it's
a prune God do like a band-aid why don't
she lays her she had laser but sometimes
I think she's laser to couch but I don't
know if she's lasered her her [ __ ] so
she was amazing her [ __ ] I've been
looking with laser my ass even when you
laser you still kind of have to touch up
like a little you know back and [ __ ]
like that
that is frequently cuz you get peach
fuzz I think a little bit kind of comes
back yeah strips did you yank off I did
like three I think what she's screaming
he's gonna like I think she's like you
know it's good yeah did you get Marni I
won't get horny too I think a little bit
cuz you're you're right in there yeah
you know I'm saying so I don't know that
I would get horny but you're witnessing
the transformation into this no I
understand what's happening okay it's
already
yeah you'll get horny I don't think I
would get horny me you might like [ __ ]
shaving porn okay I've seen them and
seen that before
I've seen that in the early 2000s where
girls would shave and then they would
[ __ ] yeah or the whole process and a guy
would shave their [ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's that's what I've seen you to
thousands it was a trend
what's the now it's the air of the POV a
lot of guys can't get it kind of old but
it's still it's always there it's always
there for a while I [ __ ] the incest
[ __ ] man it kills me when like because
sometimes I'll see it and I'll click on
someone will who are like I'm like oh
because you're kind of you know
sometimes you don't just read the titles
and you think like oh this is just an
attractive woman and then you click on
it and then and then I hear them going
into the like the in brother [ __ ] and
I'm like please just say step one time
so I can finish jerking off to this and
then they don't say step they just say
all like hug come on brother I'm like ah
I got a click out god damn it when I get
more mad that they don't look related
accurate I know I'm more mad about that
they also have to see it 70 times what
are you gonna say it 70 times I just
have to hear the point well I don't I
never hear it it's always on I can't cuz
it's so fake
you watch it with subtitles care about
the [ __ ] story
what no I need to hear it do you you
seem like the type who sits there and
reads the titles and she's like reading
the tiles like that one she reads the
paragraph description of the video I
read comments sometimes sometimes cuz
it's funny yeah they're funny but she
does like reading that [ __ ] like what
did they think of this yeah yeah yeah
you know me so well
that's a good question to ask because
this video is brought to you by
manscaped and to provide all kinds of
products for all of us dudes to shave
our nuts and I just got the landscape
I'm in the Vellamo or 3.0 I haven't
tried it yet but you said you've tried
it already yeah yeah no it's dope I like
that you can kind of you know you can
adjust your your your way trim the trim
we got one here but and uh yeah see I
like I like using that thing as opposed
to regular like shaving cuz I usually
just shave my pubes right but I feel
like shaving of the like shaving your
pubes all the way I feel like that's
kind of like in like an old thing now
like I feel like look you get ingrown
hairs and stuff I would every once in a
while yeah so I like when you use the
Clippers it leaves like kind of like a
little nice little fade fade up you
mm-hmm everything still looks very small
kempt yeah yeah it has a light on it
right cuz if you're shaving like
sometimes you want to do like that you
can see you can see in the dark man you
can use it in the shower
oh it's waterproof yeah yeah it's pretty
sweet so cute and small that's what she
so if you guys want to have your nuts
and balls and even your [ __ ] nicely
shaved we have a special code for all of
our friends out there off the record you
get 20% off and free shipping go to
manscape calm and use the code off the
record thank you there you go yeah we
still talk my point yeah okay so
speaking about the titles here's what
[ __ ] me out too is that when I think
I'm now like I'm kind of like I've tried
to be respectful of women also when I'm
watching my porn I want that before that
oh I was always respectful of women but
here's the thing now I'll read a title
where it's like oh like fat chick gets
smashed by bebe whatever right be BC and
I'm like I'll look I'm like she's not
even fat oh yeah I'm like and that's not
even a BBC yeah you should type in an
NBC they're just trying to clickbait
your ass I'm like I'm trying to watch
fat girls and then I'm like this girl's
not yeah what about like an empowered
woman takes multiple concrete really
good
empowered woman takes multiple cream
pies yeah you said you read the comments
but what's the funniest coherent nah
it's just well here's our we comments
just just to see you leave the comments
yeah oh dude there so you can you can
you can download you can share it's like
YouTube a lot of that [ __ ] makes its way
to reddit because it's pretty funny
stuff people screen happen one of my
favorite ones is who's this girl and
then immediately there's like people
answering they know exactly which video
what times oh my god now that isn't
that's a Jew fan that's you answering
I'm not even that hardcore I'm looking
at them like you guys are level thousand
yeah like they're creeps kill zone
you're pretty hardcore though you know
the era's and the trends in each era
that's your my point enthusiast but I'm
not quite the fan boy yeah was the
difference I think the hardcore ones I I
respect them I'm just like wow you guys
you you're a walking excite your in Jedi
in there Jedi Knight have you been to a
porn convention by accident yes I
actually want to go to one yeah me too
yeah I've never been I was at an anime
expo and downstairs was a porn
convention and we walked down to just
check it out and it was just like porn
star signing autographs
yeah oh so it's not anything like no
one's [ __ ] live no because I saw this
one video where there's like this one
chick she was trying to like set the new
world record or something like a fight
what like 300 dudes in like 60 seconds
or whatever oh yeah and then so there'd
be a line like a convention line tip
[ __ ] yeah and all the dudes are just
on the side is Jack you know just ready
to be hard because everyone told me
that's right something like that yeah
and I want to see something something
like that cuz she was like on this
pedestal let's say your memory would you
be down to participate in that [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
for like five snap I'm not into the
first one unless he's a fan and I don't
want to be part of us that's the core
people right there's a news reporters
like right when I come
so how is the first ten seconds keep it
up stand next to the eye line again
[Laughter]
about this like don't guys like in
college or whatever even in high school
like they'll all put on a porn and then
like jerk off no dudes I've done that
I've heard that but not looking at it
like though but they're like in
different areas of the room where they
can't see what but that's still weird
wait like having sex in the same house
is like other people that like next door
to my friend having sex like that to me
is the same really like were you're
strange
that's weird yeah I'm strange then but
to me it's just like I can't get turned
on knowing someone that I know and like
my friend is also like next door I don't
know but you don't you get that feel
like you're having a good time because
your friends are having a good if I know
my friends coming I like to know that
I'm coming story I have a story yes
ready yeah okay so one time I was doing
a show in Massachusetts right I love
message it's super fun right boss is fun
it's good see no one says Boston's fun
people either want to go to New York or
Hawaii all the shows I ever had a bad
I've never had a bad time in how dude
you're so uncool you're uncultured
swines you everyone talks about possible
you know I think really wants to know
Tomas what's it busted we don't know
they do all come and Affleck every
[ __ ] colleges oh that sounds exciting
no but coach parties do oh oh your party
booking guidance no I'm talking about
that's what people say yeah I've never
heard anyone go I can't wait to [ __ ]
go to the big [ __ ] Boston they don't
wait I call it that the big boss
I can't wait to get the big bottle never
be busted a big boss to me so I'm doing
this college show and I used to bring
Rick all the time as like my height man
right whenever I do these like these
college shows yeah but um kid even want
to be there I know he loved it so but
they would only book us one hotel room
right and I love it all so of course I'm
there all weekend with Rick and I'm like
and I'm and then one night I'm like [ __ ]
man I feel like I feel like jerking off
right so I'm like I'm like our dog on
the shower so I go to shower I'm like
got him on my shower what you said to
him [ __ ] man I feel like drinking it's
not something we wouldn't say we said
yes I'm like I I'm like I I'm gonna go
take a shower so I'm showering I'm like
oh this is perfect time to drag off
right now right and you're really
feeling that shower you're running hands
down the tiles oh yeah it was the right
time you're like I don't think I'd jerk
off in here and then yeah you just start
to slowly feel it yeah you think I've
never seen a shower like this get in the
mood I don't like jagged off in a shower
but go on so I'm in that no me neither
but this was the only time so I mean
there I'm like okay I'm about to jerk
off and here's what here's the thing
about it I wasn't in the shower I just
had the shower running and was drinking
off so that's better but you don't want
him to hear all these noises exactly so
I'm drinking off the water makes it
worse
it turns the consistency of the jizz
weird - what anyways we'll get into it
we'll get into what do you have to do
with the jizz just has to go away I just
I don't like the feeling of the jizz
after when it's on my hand the shower
water hits it let me finish my story
okay then how do you wash your hands
after like normally I wash them normally
but like I just don't like the way the
Jesus feels in my hands times a
gentleman yeah
anyways we'll get into it but anyways so
I jerk off I bust my flush it down the
toilet right I come out the shower
wait away it's more walk after my shower
I don't leave my nameís I said you don't
wanna throw the trash can [ __ ] jizz
can stink
hey did you not even take a shower no
I'm gonna turn the water on to Rick's
like don't hands like I took a shower
bye
so I finish drinking off I finished
showering I go outside I'm talk--i
brickworks like hey you know it's funny
he's like it's like you went in the
shower for a long-ass time and he's like
I realized you're probably jerking off
so he's like what better time for me to
I know he's gonna be a man he's like I
know he's gonna be in there for a while
what did he bust no probably just into
into like you know like a tissue and
throw in the trash can you know right
yeah no choice so but he's like you know
what's funny is he's like like right
after I noted talking about I'm Rick
he's like right after I noted I heard
you flush the toilet there's our
synchronized coming I guess so [ __ ] each
other like it's one thing to be with in
your shoes where you don't even know
he's jerking off with there's another
weird thing the fact that Rick is like
ah let's see we just came together it's
the weird one assuming you happy he
probably was like oh [ __ ] oh he didn't
know until after he heard the toilet
flush but he's also playing Russian
roulette cos you could've came out at
any time that's all [ __ ] and then
[ __ ] up the pool well then you would
assume that he would just you would just
hear the water go off cuz that's when I
was well what if you ran out just
kidding I was out the whole time then
he's grabbed my towel what'd he do what
would Rick do what'd he say stop I'm
jacking off
I feel like rigor polishes blue-ball
riggle probably is you know in turn
around if I was in my hotel on the job I
would be like yo dude I'm coming out
don't be jacking off because I really
soon that you're jack
[Music]